i've always wanted to make money with
stonks but every time i listen to advice
from guys on tv like jim cramer i lose a
ton of money like a few months ago he
told me to buy this technology stock
called peloton but failed to mention
it's just an exercise bike with an ipad
strap to it lost 80 on that trade then
last week he tipped me off to a stock
called netflix that one's not going too
well either and it's gone now i've got a
second mortgage on my horse but
thankfully i've learned the perfect
investment strategy listen to jim then
do the exact opposite of what he says so
in this video we're going to build an
algo trading app with javascript that
can make real trades in the stock market
based on an iron-clad ai-powered
algorithm quick disclaimer this video
does contain investment advice as long
as your strategy is to be poor all i ask
in return is that you hit the like
button and subscribe the inverse kramer
strategy is not unique but the problem
is that i don't think there's a public
api that provides jim cramer picks i had
to sell my tv so i can't watch a show
anymore which means we need to go with
plan b we'll use the world's premier ai
model gpt3 and ask it if jim cramer
would buy or sell whatever stocks we're
interested in gpt3 writes pretty much
all my code these days with github
copilot so it should really have no
problem figuring out stock picks let's
first take a look at the architecture
and tech stack of this application first
we'll need a backend server and for that
i'm using firebase cloud functions i was
going to use cloudflare because i felt
bad about how far their stock has fallen
after it was recommended by jim cramer
but i think firebase is the best fit for
this project we'll have a function
running on a cron job during market
hours that when invoked we'll make a
call to the gpt3 api generative
pre-trained transformer 3 is one of the
most sophisticated and terrifying
algorithms out there we can take a list
of stocks and simply ask it if jim
cramer would buy them or not and it will
respond with a simple yes or no and we
could even provide it more context like
kramer's recent tweets and articles to
nudge it in the right direction if the
answer is sell then we'll buy if the
answer is buy then we'll short sell now
to trade a stock we'll need a broker and
for that i'm using the alpaca api which
is basically robinhood for developers
also i'm deeply saddened and dismayed to
report that the robin hood guys are no
longer billionaires their stonk also
tanked big time after being recommended
by jim kramer alpaca is really cool
because it's commission free trading and
it also provides real-time market data
that you can use for free and if you
don't want to lose your own money it
supports paper trading in a fake
simulated environment for this tutorial
i'm using a thousand dollars of my own
money but once we get capitalized with a
few hundred million i'm going to open it
up to [ __ ] i mean retail investors or
if you want to do it yourself all the
source code is on github in all
seriousness there's a lot to learn from
this project you'll learn how to run
background jobs in the cloud on a timer
how to trade stocks and crypto with
javascript how to interact with the gpt3
algorithm with javascript and will even
build a web scraper to extract dynamic
content from sites like twitter using
puppeteer and will do it all in under
100 lines of code to get started open up
the terminal and use firebase tools to
initialize a new firebase functions
project you'll need a firebase account
to do this although this code will work
on any node.js server now let's cd into
the functions directory and installer
dependencies for openai alpaca and
puppeteer now at this point you'll need
an api key from openai to use gpt3 it's
a paid service but i believe they offer
you an 18 credit to play around and then
pricing is pay as you go after that
you'll first want to go to the
playground and try it out it will likely
rule over humans in the not so distant
future so be nice to it you can ask it
questions like is jim kramer good at
stonks it's gonna simp for him but it
should at least be able to tell us
whether or not he would buy a certain
stock now from there we'll need to get
our api key it's a secret value so make
sure not to expose it publicly now in
our firebase code we can open up the
index.js file and import the sdk there
the first thing we'll need to do is
authenticate using the organization and
api key from openai i have my keys set
up as environment variables in firebase
however you could just paste them in
directly if you want again just make
sure they don't end up in a public git
repo from there we can instantiate
openai with the configuration to start
things off i'm going to write all the
code in an http function that will allow
us to test it in the browser to make a
call to openai we can use the git
completion method there are many other
things it can do like answer questions
classify text and things like that but i
found the completion method to be most
useful for this project and keep in mind
this is a really dumb way to pick stocks
gpt3 is really cool but it's not going
to magically pick good stocks for you
the most important option is the prompt
the ai will try to complete whatever
comes next and then you have a variety
of other options you might pass here to
tweak the results openai will respond
with an object with the result so let's
go ahead and send that back as the
response from the function now open up
the terminal and run npm run serve to
run the functions locally that'll give
you a link to the browser with the
function url you should get a response
with the data from gpth3 most
importantly it has the stocks that it
thinks jim cramer will sell that's
pretty cool but it would help if we
could give gpt3 the proper context like
jim cramer's recent tweets for that
we're going to need to build a web
scraper with a tool called puppeteer
which is basically a headless browser
that you can run on the server not sure
how legal this is and this is only legal
advice if you want to go to prison we'll
first import puppeteer then create an
async function called scrape what we'll
do is launch a chromium browser on the
server and then we'll tell it to go to
jim cramer's twitter page the tweets
aren't server rendered so we're going to
tell it to wait until the network is
idle and then have it wait for an
additional three seconds after that as
well at that point the tweet should be
loaded and we can even take a screenshot
of the page just to verify now from
there we can use page evaluate to
interact with the actual content on the
webpage inside this function we'll have
access to the document where we can grab
different elements in the dom in this
case we'll just grab the entire body
text and let gpt3 deal with that you
could improve this by writing code that
only grabs tweets that talk about actual
ticker symbols now from there we can
close the browser and return the tweets
let's go back into our http function
then we'll call this great function we
just defined and interpolate that into
the prompt that we passed to openai in
theory gpt3 will try to complete jim
cramer's next tweet for him and now
we're ready to trade stocks first you'll
need to sign up for an alpaca account
and deposit some money into it or you
might use the paper trading feature it's
popular with algo traders where stock
trading is entirely automated with code
and then you'll see the option to
generate an api key and remember this is
also a secret value and you really don't
want to expose it because then someone
could trade on your account now if we go
back to our javascript code we can
import the alpaca sdk and add our api
keys to it you can also set the paper
option to true if you want to use fake
money after we get the open ai response
i'm going to create a variable called
stocks to buy that uses a little bit of
regex to grab the ticker symbols from
whatever gpt returns us and now we can
do all kinds of stuff with alpaca the
first thing we might want to do is get
our account which has important
information like our current buying
power after that buying a stock is as
easy as creating an order it'll be
looking for a ticker symbol that's the
stock that you want to buy or sell then
you can specify a quantity or it also
supports fractional shares if you want
to buy a specific dollar amount and
that's what we'll do here we'll take our
current buying power and use 90 of it to
buy a stock if you want to be extra poor
alpaca also supports trading on the
margin where you can leverage your
buying power further in this example
we'll buy the stock and then we'll make
it a market order that tells it to buy
the stock at the current available price
and the trade will only be valid for the
current day let's go ahead and send the
order object as the response now go to
the browser and refresh the page when
you do that it's going to make an actual
trade in the stock market you should get
a confirmation number back and also see
the trade in your alpaca account
congratulations you are now an algo
trader now the final thing i want to
show you is how we can run this code
every day with a cron job a cron job is
just a schedule for doing work in the
background on the server we can easily
set one up with firebase using a pub sub
function this function i'm going to give
a memory allocation of four gigabytes
because puppeteer uses a lot of memory
then we'll set up a schedule that runs
at 10 am every day monday through friday
and then it's really important to set
the time zone for the markets that you
want to trade in now from there we can
simply copy the code we just wrote and
paste it in here directly as one extra
touch i'm also going to cancel all
orders and close out all my positions
whenever this function runs that means
every day i'll sell all my stocks and
then buy a new one based on jim's
recommendations now if you're ready to
become poor run firebase deploy do you
push your code to the cloud now if you
want to track my fund's performance
follow me on twitter because i plan on
posting regular updates there to wrap
things up i want to apologize to jim
cramer i have nothing against the guy
and the reality is that nobody except
for maybe nancy pelosi's husband can't
predict the stock market kramer himself
said we are all wrong so often that it
amazes me that we can have any
conviction at all over the direction of
things to come but we must again this is
only investment advice if you want to be
poor thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one